if you've been alive for the past ten
years you've surely heard of two planes
the Airbus a380 and boeing 787
dreamliner these two planes have
dominated new cycles worldwide because
they're both intensely innovative the
a380 is the largest passenger plane to
have ever existed while the Dreamliner
is one of the most efficient and has an
unrivaled focus on passenger comfort
concealed by all the fanfare however is
a much deeper story on economics
innovation and how the airline industry
works so believe it or not work on the
Airbus a380 began back in 1988 more
people were flying than ever and
airports weren't getting all that much
bigger Airbus I'd the success of the
Boeing 747 and needed a bigger aircraft
to compete at first Airbus considered
making a super-wide jet by placing two
a340 fuselages side-by-side but later
opted for the design we see today a
fully double decker jet an a380 can
hypothetically carry as many as 868
people in an all-economy configuration
although the densest in practice is 615
seats this is more than double that of
the 787 Airbus decided to focus on
making a high-capacity aircraft because
they believed in the hub-and-spoke model
of aviation with a hub-and-spoke model
passengers traveling from smaller
airports will use Hartford Connecticut
as our example to a long-haul
destination such as London England will
need to connect through a hub passengers
would likely take a short flight to New
York Atlanta or Chicago to catch their
transatlantic flight to London obviously
this is inefficient for the passenger on
almost all routings between Hartford and
London passengers have to fly away from
their destination in order to catch
their transatlantic flight however for
Airlines
there's conceivably an advantage let's
say just for the sake of explanation
there are only six airports in the
entire United States New York Boston DC
Los Angeles San Francisco and Seattle if
an airline had a one flight from every
destination to every other destination
they would need to run sixteen routes if
they just have one hub Airport on each
coast we'll say New York and LA they
just need to have
route from each secondary airport to
each hub and one transcontinental hub to
hub route five in total obviously there
will be quite high demand on the one
transcontinental route so airlines can
put a large aircraft such as the a380 on
that route to fulfill its demand since
its release the a380 has often been
placed on those long-haul high demand
routes known as trunk routes the second
busiest long-haul route in the world
Dubai to London sees eight a380s a day
and that's in addition to five smaller
planes that fly that route the
Dreamliner serves a very different
purpose it's a pretty modest sized plane
it can only hold around 220 passengers
in a typical configuration its composite
construction makes it extremely light
and fuel efficient which helps reduce
operating costs in the late 1990s boeing
started to see slower sales on their
large 747s and 767s and started to
consider what to build next they
initially looked at creating a plane
called the sonic cruiser which would
have had this same fuel efficiency as
conventional aircraft while flying 15%
faster just under the sound barrier
airlines were initially enthused however
after the attacks on September 11th and
the rising cost of fuel airlines asked
for fuel efficiency rather than speed
the 787 delivered on that promise by
reaching up to a hundred and two miles
per gallon per seat
compared to the a380s paltry 74 miles
per gallon per seat the Dreamliner also
has an absolutely enormous range of up
to eight thousand miles and better yet
it's efficient at that range boeing made
such a relatively small aircraft because
they believed in an entirely different
model of aviation the point-to-point
model in this model in order to get
passengers from Harford to London
Airlines just run a direct flight
between Harford and London obviously
demand would be lower but there still is
demand in the past to fly a route like
this an airline would have to use an
aircraft with higher capacity than
demand because smaller airplanes
couldn't fly such a distance non-stop
given that Airlines resorted to the
hub-and-spoke model to concentrate all
the demand on certain routes where they
could fail large long
all planes now with planes like the
Dreamliner
Airlines can fly long route with less
demand while still being efficient the
hub and spoke model was also popular in
the past because Airlines believed that
it was more cost-efficient to fly less
flights at higher capacity it's simple
economics really doing a lot of one
thing together is cheaper than doing a
lot of one thing separately its
economies of scale except that doesn't
really extend to the airline industry
for a larger aircraft you need more
ground staff more flight attendants more
check-in agents more fuel more of pretty
much everything if the only cost that
stays the same as pilots and the only
ones reduce are gates and takeoffs when
you're now doing more flights at the
largest most expensive airports you end
up spending more money airports like
Hartford Connecticut are cheap labor is
cheap takeoff these are cheap everything
cost less than at JFK or Newark
they're just fewer flights to compete
with not only that but flying direct
flights clearly cost a ton less because
airlines only have to pay the per flight
costs that I talked about a lot in my
wife flying is so expensive video once
rather than twice United Airlines was a
major innovator of the point-to-point
model with their newer cub Newark is an
airport suited to serve smaller planes
so United took the opportunity to open
up direct flights to smaller
destinations on the British Isles using
narrow body planes stretched to the
upper limits of their range United
primarily uses the Boeing 757 to reach
smaller destinations like Shannon
Ireland Belfast Northern Ireland Glasgow
nan borough Scotland and Manchester
Newcastle and Birmingham England often
the United flight from Newark is the
only transatlantic flight serving these
airports United is able to operate these
routes because the east coast of the US
and the British Isles are just close
enough together to reach with a narrow
body plane with the 787 airlines are
able to open even longer route between
smaller destinations routes like these
are called long and skinny long distance
but skinny demand
these include routes like Tokyo to
Seattle London to Chennai India
and China to San Francisco Beijing to
Boston Nairobi Kenya to Paris Santiago
Chile to Madrid Warsaw Poland to Beijing
Doha to Edinburgh Scotland the list goes
on the efficiency of this plane has also
allowed for an entirely new class of
airline budget long-haul carriers these
are three main players in this category
are jet star Airlines based in Australia
scoot Airlines based in Singapore and
Norwegian Airlines based in both
Scandinavia and London short-haul budget
airlines have been possible for a while
because of efficient short-range
airplanes but this really is the first
time there has been such an efficient
long-haul airplane so these three
airlines use the reduction in operating
costs to offer significantly lower
ticket prices while also using the
principles of budget airlines that I
outlined in my Hal budget Airlines work
video what's even more exciting for us
consumers is the upcoming Boeing 737 max
this plane is a redeveloped version of
the long existing Boeing 737 featuring a
larger capacity longer range and higher
fuel efficiency this means that we could
conceivably see super low demand routes
like Manchester to Cleveland Leon to New
York and Belfast to DC operated in the
near future
Norwegian Airlines has already hinted at
plans to use a 737 Mac to open up an
auxilary transatlantic hub in Edinburgh
a relatively small city so the a380 was
a failure
Airbus hasn't received a new order in
years and it recently announced that it
would be cutting back its production to
only 12 a year meanwhile the 787 has
amassed almost 1,200 orders
point-to-point flying has always been
better for the consumer but with these
recent innovations it's now better for
Airlines - given that it's clear that
point-to-point flying is truly the
future of aviation alright I have a lot
of things to talk about so bear with me
but above all I need to thank my amazing
sponsor audible.com I personally use
audible all the time to listen to books
on the go it's a great way to learn when
they normally be difficult like when
driving working
walking and more recently I listened to
an absolutely amazing sci-fi thriller
called dark matter by Blake Crouch it's
seriously one of the best I've ever
listened to and one of the major
scientific theories used to drive the
plot is one that I talked about in a
previous video of mine let me know if
you figure out which one it is
you can listen to Dark Matter or one of
the other 250,000 titles for free when
you sign up for a 30-day free trial
using the link ww audible calm wind over
and you'll be supporting the channel
while you're at it I recently started a
patreon where every dollar contributed
goes directly into the channel and since
the launch went so well I'm going to be
looking for an animator to hire to do
some of the work so if you'd be
interested in that follow the link on
screen or in the description to get more
details and see how you can apply if
you'd like to contribute to my patreon
you can do so by clicking here you can
get early access to videos
behind-the-scenes updates stickers
t-shirts and more aside from that be
sure to check out my last video on how
much it would cost to live on the moon
by clicking here follow me on Twitter at
whenever Pro check out the fan moderated
subreddit here and most of all subscribe
to this channel by clicking here thanks
so much for watching and I'll see you in
two weeks for another Wendover
productions video